for today's classic interview we will go
back to my interview with Christopher
Snowden from July of 2014 and in the
context of a new presidential
administration and what the role of
government should be an interesting
conversation within that under that
umbrella is with regard to vices this is
a big conversation within the war on
drugs whether drugs should be illegal
decriminalized legalized and taxed just
like cigarettes or alcohol and there's
also sort of offshoot conversations to
this about sex work legalizing and
regulating sex work who does that
benefit and who does that hurt very
interesting conversation particularly
relevant now with the incoming Trump
administration the now here trump
administration we will go back to my
interview with Christopher Snowden from
2014 I'm joined today by Christopher
Snowden who is director of lifestyle
economics at the Institute of Economic
Affairs a free market think tank based
in London it's really great to talk to
you know we've been talking over the
years about taxing vices and this can be
in relation to the war on drugs here in
the US with relation to marijuana in New
York City where we broadcast our program
former Mayor Bloomberg was into taxing
sodas large sodas for example banning
large sodas and really the question I
want to start with is in your experience
what is the goal what should be the goal
of these taxes and is it effective is it
to dissuade usage is it to fund
alternative programs etc well the view I
take which is taken by many economists
is that if you go to product which is
creating negative externalities in other
words if it's causing damage or imposing
costs upon other people or the
government as a collection of people
then it's right and proper that you put
a tax on the product so that you you
claw back the money there's been lost so
the obvious example would be health care
costs eugenia of alcohol or tobacco or
drugs which was illegal there would
probably be excess healthcare costs
associated with those products with
alcohol you've also got issues to do
with policing imprisonment magistrates
costs and
so if you're able to make a decent
estimate of what the external costs are
external costs are of these products
then there's nothing wrong with putting
a tax on it so you get to that point
serve alcohol is costing 10 billion
dollars for example you put enough tax
on your beer any wine to make that ten
billion dollars but the object of that
kind of tax of the goalie in tax is not
in itself to deter the purchase that
would be more of a morality based tax a
syntax that I don't really I don't think
the government should be trying to push
people one way or the other when it
comes to their own private behavior oh
yeah when it comes to negative x
analogies nothing wrong with taxing
things is your sense that the that is
possible to accurately quantify the
dollar value of these negative
externalities in other words it you've
made it pretty clear that from a moral
standpoint you don't have a problem with
it from a practical standpoint our
government or government agencies health
agencies able to accurately quantify
what that amount of money is
theoretically yes and there are other
studies that come out to try to do this
I write actually a lot about about this
particular issue because these cost
studies are almost universally misused
they're often quite flawed to start with
but then they get misrepresented the
most common trick is to try and put a
dollar value on emotional costs for
example so it could be bereavement or an
injury or even being upset I've seen
custody is where they try and quantify
how to set people are by seeing vomit or
littering the streets as a result of
alcohol use they're not reading
legitimate costs because they're not
financial and if you go to put a tax on
something across its financial similarly
you'll have cost to do we lost
productivity I lost productivity can be
a major cost but who does it fall and
doesn't fall in the government falls on
the individual first and foremost and
may also have some kind of effect on
businesses but whilst those are real
costs in terms of income for gone
they're not cost to the government and
we can only justify attacks on a product
which ultimately of course is going to
go to the government if it's a
government costs so
you can to your question yes we can and
we don't do it very well but you can
make a reasonable estimate of how much
drinking or smoking costs a health
service the other thing you need to do
and this is very rarely done as you
asked me to look at the benefit and
people find it very distasteful to talk
about the benefits of alcohol-related
harm or smoke eroded on but you need to
do that if you're going to make a
serious economic case in it the kind of
thing I'm talking about is if you've got
a product which kills people seven or
eight years early as as smoking does
yeah there are clear costs involved in
treating smoking-related diseases but
your question you want to know is what
are the costs over the course of a
lifetime you want to compare the health
care costs of a nonsmoker over a
lifetime with the costs of the smoker
and anybody who dies after the age of 65
is going to save the government money
the younger they die this is the simple
hard truth once people are not paying
taxes anymore and there they go from
being somebody who's Annette contributed
to the pot to being someone who's
Annette take her from the part in terms
of pensions welfare prescription charges
nursing home brewer and all these kind
of things then the government now she
doesn't save money so the optimum person
from from a purely economic point of
view for the state is somebody who drops
dead at the age of 65 preferably from
something very quick like a heart attack
so you do need to look at the benefits
as well as the cops before you try and
work out these figures but it can be
done we can to average or reasonably
satisfactory estimate it can be done
I've read a lot of your work and I've
also looked at a lot of other research
and as my audience will know very very
clearly over the years I've had trouble
taking a firm position on these types of
taxes because on the one hand I do
sympathize and find a lot of logic and
the types of arguments that you make at
the same time and I'll cite some of the
numbers from the US CDC the Center for
Disease Control with a cigarette tax for
example in 2009 the Federal cigarette
tax so set putting aside the state tax
on cigarettes rose from 39 cents to a
dollar and one cent per pack and
supposedly if we are to believe the
numbers this reduced
number of smokers by about 3 million
smokers over the three-year period that
followed from two thousand nine to
twenty twelve now if you if we follow
the full chain of costs and benefits and
so on and so forth the idea is that
there is a net savings here but you say
that we shouldn't really be influenced
by that necessarily that this type of
tax may not really be do you say it's
not a moral tax or is it not the
government's role to impose this kind of
tax I I think it's immoral and I think
it's not the government's role to impose
those taxes so let's take it piece by
piece though so what first why is it the
immoral part I wake up I believe that
people should be free to live their life
as they choose so long as they don't
interfere with other people's rights and
the only way in which people are
interfering people's rights to smoking
aside from the second hand smoke issue
is if they're placing an excess cost on
the welfare state and are they not are
they not doing that though in other
words i know that in in the UK the
health care system is quite different
from that here in the US there's no
question about that but certainly having
more smokers in the entire risk pool for
health insurance is imposing a cost on
others who are not smokers is it not if
you just looked at it from the sums of
Health possibly although even then it's
quite doubtful actually but I yeah I'm
coming from a British respective I'm
looking from respective in the entire
welfare pot so I'm including pensions in
that church is the single biggest source
of expenditure in the welfare state so
um what you might lose in terms of
health care you actually gain in terms
of pensions and their arch and we were
smoking is is unusual and
counterintuitive because unlike obesity
where the evidence is more mixed and
unlike alcohol where there is a clear
net negative externality we're smoking
the evidence suggests that even if you
didn't have any tax on cigarettes at all
it would still provide an X aiming to
the government and if that is that
because people would be dying earlier
and therefore imposing a smaller cast
over their lifetime as you exactly what
it is and it's not just smoking anything
that prolongs life any kind of
preventative meds tends to be expensive
it's a great myth in public health that
if you get people living longer then
you're going to save on health care
costs you don't you just have different
sorts of health care costs the short
lethal diseases are much cheaper to
treat them along chronic diseases and
the diseases of old age things like
dementia but also you know the hip
operations or cataract operations the
amount of medication people need as they
get older these are all very expensive
you know the aging population is a real
issue for the welfare state he leaves
the expensive having an Asian population
which it cause it not to say that we
shouldn't be trying to have an aging
population of course yeah and it's
interesting you mention that because i
don't know if you heard during the
debate over the Affordable Care Act here
in the US there were many on the left
who characterized the idea of those on
the right as do not get sick but if you
do die very quickly in order to not
incur significant costs and and what
you're saying is that there is actually
some truth to that that that is a way to
hold down costs which is either by
keeping people healthy or by ensuring
not insuring but hoping that when they
get sick that they died relatively
quickly yeah yeah that's basically how
it is I mean as I say from an economic
point of view the optimum citizen in
terms of saving money is somebody who
works until the 65 knows that never has
a day off doesn't get any kind of
chronic diseases but then this suddenly
dropped dead now that's not to say it's
optimum for society we need to separate
the model object of course the economic
Egyptian it would be ideal that
everybody lived a perfectly healthy life
to the age of hundreds and then drop
dead from something very quick but
that's not going to happen either so all
I'm saying is yes we want people to to
live longer or in person want people to
live their own lives first and foremost
but of course most people would rather
live long with them that the shorter
amount of time but we shouldn't fool
ourselves that by how many people given
up smoking or cutting down on various
and healthy habits
now we're going to save money because
we're not the options going out last
thing and we do have limited time left
when it comes to the legalization and
regulation and taxation of sex work is
there an analysis that is similar to the
one you make for cigarettes for example
or is the analysis different I think the
primary argument for legalizing sex work
is much the same as the argument for
legalizing drugs which is that just by
having it legal and regulated you make
it less harmful for everybody involved
you could obviously come up with a
estimate of the the costs that come from
both the war on drugs and the
criminalization of prostitution there
will be costs on both sides of course
that we cost if you have it legal bill
because at the moment as you have it
illegal see ya you could do an economic
study at that but I think the primary
the firm a justification for legalizing
these kind of activities isn't that it
will necessarily save money although I
think it clearly will in the case of
drugs because you can attach them and
you won't have to spend tens of billions
of dollars trying to place the existing
laws right um I think the main thing is
it actually makes things safer and
better for every all right we've been
speaking with Christopher Snowden
director of lifestyle economics at the
Institute of Economic Affairs thanks so
much for joining us very interesting I